die bilder aus bayern und den alten
lassen es erahnen
dieses jahr haben wir es mit einem
besonderen winter zu tun
der grund für die extremen
wetterverhältnisse liegt hoch über uns
in der stratosphäre
jedes jahr im herbst bildet sich der
sogenannte polarwirbel eine zirkulation
kalter luftmassen um minus 80 grad
angetrieben wird der wirbel von einem
tief dass über dem nordpol kreist er
dreht sich gegen den uhrzeigersinn und
schaufelt so die luftmassen von west
nach ost
je höher der temperaturunterschied
zwischen nordpol und den tropen desto
stärker rotiert der polarwirbel diese
verwirbelungen wirken sich auch auf den
jetstream aus den für unser wetter so
wichtigen höhenwind in der troposphäre
meteorologen haben anfang januar ein
skurriles phänomen beobachtet dass den
polarwirbel zum erliegen bringen kann
etwa alle zwei jahre kommt es zu einer
sogenannten plötzlichen stratosphären
erwärmung tritt dieser 1 steht uns
häufig ein besonders kalter winter bevor
innerhalb weniger tage steigt die
temperatur in der stratosphäre über dem
nordpol explosionsartig an teilweise um
mehr als 100 grad
diese erwärmung deformiert den
polarwirbel oder c schlägt ihn in zwei
kleinere wirbel
das beeinflusst auch den wind lässt nach
außen kliniken von ost nachrichten
bringen
erreicht der ostwind aus der
stratosphäre auch die unteren wind
schichten steigt die wahrscheinlichkeit
eines heftigen wintereinbruchs in europa
statt milder luft vom atlantik weht ein
eiskalter arktis luft auf dem kontinent
diese kaltluft vorstöße sind sehr
beständig und von langer dauer an die
bilder aus bayern sollten wir uns also
schon einmal gewöhnen